good evening and thank you for joining
us i'm trey gowdy and welcome to sunday
night in america have you ever wondered
who decides what makes the news
much of the debate in our country is
over the way news is covered and whether
it's fair and factual but there's also
the issue of what is considered
newsworthy
this week we learned the
great-granddaughter of billionaire j
paul getty had a wedding and her wedding
dress was made of broken mirrors
we know this because the media was
obsessed with it i mean lots of folks
got married last weekend but they didn't
have nancy pelosi officiate or gather
news from attend or adorn the wedding
party with broken glass
incidentally someone in our home broke
some glass swing in a golf club over the
weekend and i can honestly tell you i
never thought about making those broken
pieces of glass into a tie or a shirt
i was just trying to get it cleaned up
before my wife found out about it
but the media around the world thinks we
need to know a really rich couple got
married and the bride wore a dress in
which you could see your reflection
and then we have the billionaire race to
space the media is also obsessed with
rich men competing to see who will be
the first to take a joy ride and rock it
and the media treats this like it's a
serious story worthy of your time like
it's novel and fresh but we already know
this story from greek and roman
mythology
a guy looked into a pool of water and he
saw his reflection and he fell in love
with himself
the only difference is the modern-day
guy had on a ridiculous cowboy hat
and compared his life to that of hourly
workers and amazon plants
the news industry is 24 hours a day
seven days a week even if the news is
not
things not really worthy of your time
are elevated and you're told this must
be really important because they keep
showing it to you
meanwhile the media skips the things we
should be seeing
life and death things like children
starving to death in ethiopia children
eating leaves just to stay alive
children eating roots just to stay alive
parents deciding which child to feed and
which ones can go hungry just a little
bit longer
we already know rich people think highly
of themselves and find new and creative
ways to waste money
but we should know god's children are
starving to death
chances are you and i won't have a
wedding dress made of broken mirrors or
take a ride on a rocket honoring dr
sigmund freud
we don't have the money and even if we
did we wouldn't spend it that way
but we can help children starving to
death for just a dollar
we can feed two children for a day that
cowboy hat alone
would feed a child for two years
if only we knew about it if only we saw
it
if only it was considered
news hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else